- [Sal] Let's do some practice examples
from our intro to slope
y intercept exercise.
What is the slope of y is equal to
negative four x minus three?
So you might already recognize,
this is in slope intercept form.
Just as a reminder,
slope intercept form is
y is equal to
mx plus b,
where the coefficient on
this x term right over here,
that is our slope,
and then this constant right over here,
that is going to give
you your y intercept.
So if they're saying,
what is the slope here?
Well I just need to figure out,
what is the coefficient on this x term?
And you can see that the coefficient here
is a negative four.
So that is going to be our m,
that is going to be our slope.
Now just as a reminder,
you have to make sure
that it's solved in this way,
that is is solved for y,
y is equal to something
times x minus three,
so that's our slope.
Let's do another one of these.
So we're asked, what is the y intercept
of y is equal to negative
three x minus two?
So once again we already have
it in slope intercept form.
It's already been solved for y.
It's of the form y is equal to mx plus b,
where m, our slope, is
given right over here,
negative three.
But they're not asking for our slope,
they're asking for the y intercept.
Well the y intercept is given by b here,
so b is negative two.
Pay close attention to the sign here.
So b is equal to negative two.
But when I look at these choices,
I don't see a b is equal to negative two,
so what are they talking about?
Well a y intercept is,
what is the y value
when x is equal to zero?
And you could see that here,
if x was equal to zero
then that term goes away
and y is equal to b.
So if you want to know the point where
the graph described by this equation
intercepts the y axis,
well it's going to be what
is y when x is equal to zero?
Well when x is equal to zero,
y is equal to negative two.
And you could see that in
our original equation, again.
If x were zero, this term would go away,
and y would be equal to negative two.
So zero, comma, negative two.
So it would be that
choice right over there.
On Khan Academy obviously you
just have to click on that,
you don't have to shade it in.
Let's do one more.
Complete the equation of the
line whose slope is five,
and y intercept is zero, comma, four.
So once again the general form is
y is equal to our slope times x,
if I want to put it in
slope intercept form,
plus our y intercept.
Well they're telling
us, our slope is five.
Whose slope is five.
So we know that m is going to be five.
And they tell us that the
y intercept is zero, four.
So the y intercept, b,
that is the value of y
when x is equal to zero.
So the value of y when x equals zero
is this four right over here.
So that is going to be four.
So I could say y is equal to
five times x plus four.
And when you're actually
entering it on Khan Academy,
you would just type it in,
or if you're using the app
you would use it with your finger.
And I always make the
mistake of writing y equals,
and I type in y equals five x plus four.
Notice they already gave you
the y equals right over there.
That's all you have to do,
recognize the slope, the y intercept,
and then remember what the slope
intercept form actually is.